bel arbi y est
c'est leur marque et sa femme ont opté
pour une essences méditerranéennes un
arbousiers qui ne réclament pas beaucoup
d'eau qui tient très bien le gel avec le
réchauffement climatique certains arbres
ont tendance à disparaître de leur
terrain les boulots par exemple bongo en
ce moment donc ils disparaissent par
contre on voit arriver des châtaigniers
vont arriver des plus de jeunes et
calmes en face aux périodes de
sécheresses récurrentes
les pépiniéristes ont su adapter leur
offre en proposant des plantes plus
résistantes
la tendance aujourd'hui elle est
persistante comme tous les légumes comme
les femmes c'est une grande famille
aujourd'hui entre les lucides hommes les
texanes hommes les japonais nikon tout
ça c'est des persistant c'est des
ambitions très très très résistant à la
sécheresse et puis aussi au climat qu'on
peut voir depuis quelques années la
foire aux arbres de sandillon de
novembre elle est encore très couru pour
ces arbres fruitiers et là aussi la
hausse des températures a vu
l'apparition au nord de notre région de
la culture de nouvelles espèces
maintenant qu'il fait plus chaud en fait
à bord peut se permettre d'avoir des
figues et où des kiwis ça va bien puis
c'est en fait le jonc l'achat de plus de
ponte plus exotiques comme la fugue et
de kaki des olives toussaint de
citronniers les plantes exotiques
alain pépiniéristes du maine et loire en
a fait sa spécialité des essences
également très adapté à cette période de
transition climatique depuis 5 6 ans et
des agaves des agaves qui vient de la
cordillère des andes à 4000 mètres
d'altitude ou qui fait des -20 l'hiver
et des plus de cinquante l'été plantes
exotiques ou classique
elles ont en commun de demander un
arrosage régulier la première année de
leur plantation
alors l'été prochain pensez à stocker
l'eau au cas où la pluie ne viendrait
pas